how's it going everybody I've got some
really exciting news for you today most
of you are aware of this but for those
of you who are not the Russo brothers
are doing a private screening of
Avengers infinity war and a Q&A
immediately following partnering up with
Collider at our Clyde cinemas this is
happening this upcoming Wednesday
November 28th and it's a pretty big deal
because this is the day before November
29th which marked the one-year
anniversary of the first teaser trailer
for Avengers infinity war coming out so
a lot of people think that we might
actually get the trailer on November
29th and a lot of people actually think
that on November 28th when they do the
private screening the people who are in
attendance might actually get to see the
Avengers 4 trailer this is huge because
one it might tell us when the trailer
comes out - it should definitely tell us
the title if they see the trailer and
three if they show the trailer then
we're going to have an official accurate
description of the trailer and a lot of
people have asked me if I've entered the
contest and have been chosen to go to
Hollywood to see the screening and the
QA no I haven't but a friend that I'm
very close with has he's very close with
IMAX and he's friends with colliders
well and he has been invited to the
screening so he told me he's going to
keep me and everybody updated on
whatever happens at the QA and he's also
going to meet the Russo brothers after
as well so he's going to keep me
informed and he's going to post about
everything that happens during the QA
and everything he learns about at
vendors 4 so be sure to follow him on
Twitter because he'll be updating
everybody his Twitter is at I'm a film
editor and be sure to follow me at the
CW official because I'll be posting
updates on what he tells me and of
course be doing a video about the QA as
well so again we're not sure what's
going to happen but I have somebody on
the inside and he's going to let me know
everything that happens during the
screening and during the QA so be sure
to subscribe to my channel with the
notifications turned on so you can get
updated on everything that happens
during the screening and QA as soon as
possible going back to the prelude for
Avengers 4 it comes out December 5th so
we should get the trailer before then
and if we get any type of information
from this event I will let you know asap
I know everybody is getting really
impatient myself included but
it is all happening really really soon
be sure to subscribe comment and like
the video so you can enter my giveaway
check out the details for that down
below and so you can stay up to date on
everything related to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]